Sam Sam coming welcome to free pal what
is that oh yeah I made this so I don't
have to put on a shirt whenever you call
me the window just saves time
hey Chrissy's birthday is coming up I
have to get her something do you think a
scarf for your wife is too impersonal
I don't want something a little bit more
appropriate okay I do sir now on to the
topic of your wife's birthday presents
may I suggest some kibble or a chew toy
something to help her clean her teeth
I just love Chrissy so much I want to
make this day special for and why do you
think you feel this way stop all who's
lying with those things how many those
do have tons all right I'm not married
okay I've got a lot of free time and
disposable income oh you know what she'd
love Nexus Vegas he's in Windsor she's
been going on and on about it you know
she has been singing too close a lot
lately I think she thinks you bought
tickets already and I know they're sold
out I mean scarfs good too
maybe like one of those leather ones
with a buckle in front and you like a
little name tag on it says fight oh
don't be mean now I gotta go online see
if I can get tickets god dang it good
night bud made the old a
you